we're in the middle of our first ever
designed by drew segment where i get to
surprise this very special family of
five
essential workers with a backyard
transformation
check this out they have no idea what's
about to happen
i'm so excited i love surprises the
copenings have
no idea this is happening the team was
able to pull
this off in five hours behind their
backs we plotted and schemed
and yay i hope they like it so much
i really want to thank our friends at
weber they
were kind enough to gift the weber
genesis to the copening family
and uni they're a pizza oven company
they kindly donated this
beautiful outdoor pizza oven and this
entire stand
i'd like to give a special shout out to
tyson as well
because they've gifted the copenings
groceries for the year
synlawn donated the grass then we also
were able to work with pottery barn and
they
were able to give us these amazing table
and chairs
and this gorgeous couch and we talked
about should we do something really
colorful for the copings
and my design aesthetic is usually
very color forward but lately because of
the state of the world
it's so chaotic out there that i keep
wanting to create spaces
that are very calm and very neutral and
don't maximize more than three colors
i'm really happy with the end result and
i hope they like it too
okay i think they're here i'll be right
[Applause]
back
i'm going to be adopted into your family
oh
you got it drew you'll come right in
front of mike mike
[Laughter]
and shakia you're like the queen
entertainer yeah the games and the
karaoke so i brought some like games
for you and i brought some grilling
books
for you i know you're the grill master
i am so happy to be in your backyard
i'm trespassing down
relax and yeah patio your new beautiful
backyard
okay this is beautiful
why us i'm so like i'm excited that it's
us but i'm like
us can i just ask them one thing can we
keep this yard this
going yard oh my god i love it i love it
i can't decide who does a more important
job
and the world is in a different space
where it has a new
name essential there are new capes
there's
respect there's heroes and
for that i'm so grateful for what you
guys do
and so we wanted to show you our
appreciation
by hooking you up
how was it working in assisted living
during coronavirus
did it change you as a person to be a
part
of so much of passing on yes
it changed me definitely even though me
and my family were close we got closer
because you really got to understand who
you can depend on
to just like still be able to come home
and have our unit
you know be safe be healthy and be in a
place where we can still like
celebrate and enjoy each other you work
at the mta yes
and papa mike yeah you're you work at
the mta
and you are at the post office yes has
24 years
mail is so important yes it is so
important thank you i'm like one of your
biggest fans
thank you i'm glad to know did y'all
hear that bus operators teachers too
that's right and you're a teacher
yes my favorite thing obviously there's
so much work to do
but the fact that 2020
has doctors and nurses and teachers
and bus drivers and the post office and
everything
may we never ever ever not be in the
lane we are in right now
yes so thank you and if i had to draw i
would do it all again
yeah i would do it all again i love you
so much it hurts i love you i love you
i cannot thank you guys enough
for having me in your home that's your
family home that you grew up in
yeah and you're keeping it going by
raising your own kids here
well i wish i could hug you guys i wish
i could squeeze
[Music]
this is the best day yeah of the year
thank you joe we love you so much we
love you
[Music]
what a wonderful family we thank you for
all that you do
and to you watching do you have a space
that needs help or know someone who
deserves a special surprise
please go to our website and tell me all
about it
you